[Musique]
c'est un record absolu en amérique du
nord dans le village de lytton dans
l'ouest canadien
le record national de chaleur est passé
de 45 à 49 6 degrés pour les habitants
de vancouver dans la même région
le défi c'est de sortir de son
appartement et trouver un coin l'ombre
j'ai amené mon chien faire une balade
mais il est pas très coopératif les
chiens jamie dans les expressions
françaises c'est le malheur quand il
pleut on dit qu'il fait un temps de
chien quand il fait trop ce qu'est ce
qu'on dit jamie on parle de canicule du
latin canicule à qui veut dire petite
chienne c'était le surnom qu'on donnait
à une étoile considéré comme l'étoile de
la chaleur montre nous ton tatouages
oh non non je pensais pas à ça aimanté
vraiment ouais j'aime ça j'aime
non non non c'est pas ça fais pas ça et
surtout pas quand on est jeune et jolie
comme ça c'est pas ça
michel polnareff a posté ce message mon
public me manque corriger une heure plus
tard en mon public me manque
de quoi déclencher l'hilarité des
internautes sur ce message
un poil bizarre certains l'imaginent
avoir pris un peu trop de poids d'autres
l'invite à regarder sur leboncoin sait
jamais il tony hartmann 75 ans n'est
peut-être pas un chef étoilé
tout passe par le net mais c'est un chef
réputé dans toute l'alsace pour sa
créativité culinaire et son sens de
l'humour
l'important c'est d'avoir une très bonne
saucisse c'est une très bonne vanne
c'est léger c'est frais c'est le merde
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle un adultère
c'est qu'un enfant quand les jeunes
appellent ça intéressant quand on
grandit on dit que et adultes et
regardez vous par exemple que la mort de
son petit stade il taire je suis adulte
terme
tu sais vous quand un homme est
malhonnête on le traite de canaille
ça vient aussi de canisses donc chien
quand il est trompé par sa femme
on dit que c'est un corniaud ce qui veut
dire chien bâtard même le mot cynique
vient de q1 en grec qui veut dire chiens
les philosophe cynique comme diogène
étaient ceux qui se comporter en société
comme des chiens ils urinaient partout
se promenait à moitié à poil
bref les anciens punk quoi et si là si
on voulait se lâcher à peu mettre le feu
faire la poche à ce que vous auriez une
idée on se met tenu à tort de les
réparer car et on est carré on avait dit
oui tu vas voir
un tram sur m6 c'est foutu va être aux
côtés des plus grandes stars écoutez les
plus grandes chansons là il se passe
rien on l'attendait qu'est-ce qui se
passe
ah non ça monte trop vite non mais je
déteste ces sensations fortes on va pas
des deux entendre
qu'est ce que vous faites alors je ne
suis pas thomas pesquet je suis marie
porto la notion peut redescendre de 300
kg à bercy franchement c'est pas ni suis
tellement émouvant bellac chine et
plymouth l'élimination des bleus a aussi
était particulièrement fêté en belgique
où le fameux somme de la coupe du monde
2018 visiblement toujours très vif des
scènes de liesse quand tu aimes bape et
a manqué son tir au but des coups de
klaxon tard dans la nuit à bruxelles ou
à charleroi
certains sont même allés un peu trop
loin puisqu'on a aussi vu passer des
images de drapeaux français brûlés le
genre de scène qui me donne un peu envie
d'être pour l'italie vendredi soir dans
son quart de finale face au belge avoue
jean pierre bacri
oui vous dis oui on est bien français
jean pierre bacri oui c'est mon
compagnon lui c'est pourquoi
compatriotes il venait de l'yonne
non non non il y pense c'est quoi un
même pays que moi mais chers
compatriotes a le même pays que moi
aussi alors non pourquoi non non je suis
français moi à oui oui oui mais bon je
veux dire excusez moi
gérard vous savez que vous êtes si vous
aviez été à la place de jordan bardella
est ce que vous auriez émargé dans ce
bureau de vote
ah non j'aurais refusé d'ailleurs je
trouve que cette image est
catastrophique de le voir signer devant
cette femme voilée qui porte un voile
qui est un message politique est comme
vous le savez les présidents de bureaux
de vote sont astreints à la neutralité
politique et religieuse
quelle vie répond perso si je vois une
femme vous allez sam influencera juste à
penser qu'elles ont un sens de la
république infiniment plus prononcée que
celle qui cherche à les faire se cacher
depuis 40 ans au nom d'une laïcité
qu'ils ne comprennent absolument pas le
mot licencieux est ce que vous
connaissez
oui mais je dors dans à licencieux
autrement dit qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
licencieux c'est ali où il n'ya pas de
toi c'est magnifique qu'est ce que c'est
alors c'est de la calligraphie sur le
sable sur le sable ça vous prend
beaucoup de temps pour faire ça ça là ça
m'a pris deux heures passent deux heures
presque ray mais vous rendez compte que
ça va disparaître une fois que la mer
var matin
wii se vend bien complet ouais c'est ça
qui me plaît j'aime bien le côté
éphémère justement
c'est un peu comme la vie c'était
féerique c'était le futur vraiment bah
oui parce que moi j'avais un petit peu
peur justement d'arriver dans le futur
trop vite oui eh ben on y arriver ce
soir je suis écrivain surtout j'ai écrit
des livres de science-fiction et
d'anticipation et j'ai l'impression
depuis un an et demi qu'on vit dans un
monde petit à petit un monde parle est
long on oblique petit à petit dans un
monde à mi chemin entre 1984 et le
meilleur des mondes ou des choses qu'on
a pu lire dans des romans dans les
années 80-90 très avec par petites
touches pointilliste comme ça arrive
comment ça ça commence à ressembler à ce
monde de fiction que j'ai découvert dans
des romans ils font la fierté des
autorités grecques deux tableaux de
maîtres dont un picasso volés en 2012
enfin retrouvé par la police la
récupération des tableaux de picasso et
de mondrian a été un énorme succès pour
nous et les tableaux auront la place
qu'il mérite dans la nouvelle galerie
nationale devant la presse un bep
ministre jubile quand soudain le tableau
décroche plus de peur que de mal
heureusement
et la réalité toujours beaucoup plus
subtil et intéressante que la fiction il
s'agit de savon en forme de tablette de
chocolat et on les avait laissé traîner
sur ce plateau nathalie qui arrive
toujours la première en plateau à vous
dégoûter c'est bien du savon on en reste
à 10 c'est vrai que ses limites il se
filmer en train de rouler à 214 km heure
sur le périphérique lyonnais limitée à
70 le chauffard de 21 ans qui faisait
l'objet d'un appel à témoins lancé par
la police lyonnaise a finalement été
interpellé lundi à bron
l'individu est bien connu des services
de police pour de multiples infractions
sur la route s'il a déjà accumulé
jusqu'à onze mille euros de pv
n'avait plus de permis depuis le début
de l'année la connerie n'est pas
remboursée par les assurances sociales
vous finirez sur la paille au mal ça